[Musica]
mondo reale o mondo digitale
online ci sentiamo liberi di esprimerci
e un commento non può far male nessuno È
solo un commento Eppure il 52% di chi
subisce cyberbullismo si infligge dolore
fisico fino a meditare il suicidio fatto
molto reale
l'amore online è una finzione Eppure una
coppia su tre nasce online Alcuni hanno
poi costruito una famiglia la propria
vita
oggi online ci lavoriamo ci giochiamo ci
conosciamo
oggi il 20% dei giovani non possiede un
PC o un tablet sono esclusi sono isolati
non possiedono un canale per
socializzare con i propri coetanei
che ci piaccia o no siamo nell'epoca
della tecnologia
E imparare ad usare lo smartphone viene
più naturale che imparare ad andare in
bicicletta già in tenera età
Che differenza c'è tra ciò che riteniamo
reale e ciò che è digitale
forse nessuna Mi spiego meglio
se solo per un istante
mettessimo tutti da parte l'idea che il
digitale sia Social Ciao chat internet
smartphone e ci soffermassimo su ciò che
rimane
l'esperienza umana
Insomma come vi sentite quando subito
spedite un insulto aggressivo cosa vi
rimane Quando chiudete una conversazione
via chat con qualcuno
rimangono le emozioni e quelle non sono
digitali Quelle sono molto reali online
e offline
possiamo dire quindi che il mondo
digitale è un'estensione del mondo reale
che è un enorme impatto sulle persone e
aggiungo forse sui più giovani che fanno
di internet il proprio diario personale
questo impatto è anche amplificato
Eppure spesso assumiamo degli
atteggiamenti online che normalmente
eviteremo
Torno al confronto con il bambino che
impara per la prima volta ad andare in
bicicletta prima con le rotelle poi
senza poi il genitore tiene il sellino
Qui addirittura i genitori sono due ad
aiutare il bambino a stare in equilibrio
il bambino che invece per la prima volta
impara ad usare lo smartphone non ha
rotelle ma soprattutto non ha nessuno a
tenere il sellino prima che sia pronto a
mantenersi in equilibrio
Sì perché più stare in equilibrio
dobbiamo essere preparati dobbiamo
essere educati Ma chi ci ha educato al
digitale
Se ci pensate nessuno ci ha dato una
bicicletta con le rotelle pure oggi ci
muoviamo su moto cross con completa
naturalezza fa parte della nostra vita
fa parte della vita di tutti
questo disallineamento di conoscenza non
ci ha permesso di maturare un'adeguata
consapevolezza di ciò che il mondo
digitale e non si è fermata qui oggi la
transizione digitale domani il metaverso
questo Gap lo chiamiamo divario digitale
o digital divide
e impatta diverse sfere della vita di
ognuno di noi presente e futura
non avendo qualcuno che ci guidi e che
ci accompagni nel processo di
digitalizzazione ci sentiamo soli
e tutto ciò Ha delle conseguenze
conseguenze che per me sono sempre state
molto chiare
quel senso di confusione quella rabbia
che non si può esprimere Perché di fatto
non sai chi ti sta attaccando E perché
quel senso di impotenza nel riuscire a
proteggersi e proteggere chi ci è caro
io queste sensazioni le conosco molto
bene hanno fatto parte della mia
adolescenza
conversazioni e momenti che ritenevo
privati a disposizione di tutti
ricevere per mesi messaggi di odio E
talvolta minacce di morte da completi
sconosciuti convinti di sapere di essere
in diritto di sentenziare sulla base di
voci distorte pilotate di condivide su
chat e gruppi di centinaia e centinaia
di utenti Anzi persone le stesse pronte
ad aggredire persone a me care la cui
unica loro colpa era proprio quella di
essere mie amiche
Ma del resto so anche molto bene che lo
stesso tetro mondo digitale se
utilizzato con coscienza può essere
fonte di opportunità opportunità che
determinano la vita delle persone se
oggi sono qui se so cosa significhi
innamorarsi avere persone su cui poter
contare ottenere un lavoro con cui
mantenersi è proprio Grazie allo stesso
digitale
non molto tempo fa mi sono chiesto se
fosse possibile fare qualcosa per fare
meglio
la verità parlare di digital divide in
Italia risulta alienante e allora mi
sono detto se non io chi
nel 2019 nasce un'idea l'associazione no
profit in lotta con il digital divide in
questi ultimi tre anni mi sono impegnato
a coltivare una community di volontari
per la realizzazione di progetti con la
finalità di diffondere consapevolezza di
ciò che è il mondo digitale
Oggi siamo circa 40 in tutta Italia
siamo persone di ogni genere età e
settore di competenza dai più tecnici ai
più umanistici
essere parte di un'idea significa
conoscere i reali valori dell'umanità
proprio grazie ad un'idea Ho imparato
che la solidarietà esiste ed è spontanea
ho visto giovani adolescenti passare
pomeriggio divertendosi e imparando ad
aggiustare PC da poi donare loro
coetanei meno fortunati
un'idea mi ha anche insegnato che il GAP
generazionale è un limite di
comunicazione non di età ho visto un
quarantenne un diciannovenne aprirsi
all'ascolto scambiarsi esperienze e
punti di vista è proprio da qui è nato
un incontro con 1.500 studenti in tema
privacy online
ora immaginate tutti voi di avere un
luogo e un momento in cui potervi
scambiare competenze opinioni ed
esperienze
lo fate dopo il lavoro
lo fate dopo lo studio o lo fate nel
weekend ma soprattutto lo fate con un
obiettivo comune
investire il proprio tempo prezioso per
fare del bene perché veramente chiunque
può contribuire a rendere migliore il
mondo digitale e i nostri meravigliosi
volontari già lo stanno facendo se tre
anni fa mi aveste raccontato di un'idea
vi avrei detto che ci sarebbero stati
mille mila difetti che non avrebbe
potuto funzionare che sarebbe stato
impossibile eppure eccomi qui
La verità è che un'idea tramite tutti
coloro che hanno deciso di farene parte
mi ha cambiato abbiamo deciso di
crederci insieme e oggi ho qualcosa che
tre anni fa non avevo
ho speranza
ho speranza che si possa vivere meglio
online Dovremmo solo ricordarci più
spesso di chi è composto le umane
persone
all'inizio ho fatto una domanda
noi di un'idea abbiamo voluto provare a
dare una risposta di cui ne abbiamo
fatto un motto
Yes Digital but Human Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]